the victim has been cut in half all
organs removed blood drained from the
body and the mouth sliced ear to ear
it was the most notorious murder in
California history to the public
it was a sensation will be to us you'll
become an obsession
there's no time o clock
hey you guys episode 104 104 already I
know right Black Dahlia yes this is
about the Black Dahlia case this is
something I mean I know it's kind of
like a widely known topic but this has
been requested a lot of times yeah some
we have to cover it and yeah it's kind
of one of those forces well it's kind of
like the last show that we do better
ancient aliens and stuff it's one of
those things if you do a show like we do
eventually you have to get around you
know it's just kind of like you have to
do you have to do Black Dahlia you have
to do ancient aliens that's just how it
works
and I actually wrote about the Black
Dahlia case and a possibly related case
called the Georgia Bower Dorf murder
which was in my first book the faceless
villain yeah
sinking of the second book is almost
ready like three chapters three chapters
left yeah and we have some announcements
to make yeah we have a whole bunch of
announcements before we yeah these are
really positive announcements that that
you guys are gonna be pleased one we
bought a new studio yes we're not using
it yet cuz it has not arrived but we
have ordered it two or three more shows
probably yeah yeah it'll probably be
next week's show maybe the movie review
I'm not really sure depends on when it
arrives and how long it takes us to
figure out how to you got a lighting yep
we got chromakey background
yep brand new microphone yes supposed to
be a pretty good one it's one of those
damn Yeti black yeah things we'll have
to see how that goes yeah I got a good
deal on it and got a new HD camera and a
tripod yep
so the show wool we're gonna change the
format a little bit starting today
actually it's gonna be video the whole
way through yeah and then as we need
photos she's gonna bring them up and pop
them into the screen yeah for right now
and that's gonna look crude today but
once the studios in effect we're gonna
have a background we're gonna have
banners it's been kinda like a news show
yeah we're looking where it's gonna yeah
we're trying to like up the game of this
show yeah so it's gonna be kind of like
hit and miss for a few weeks until we
figure it out but like I said it's it's
weird because at first when we were
talking about oh we should do the whole
show and video and stuff like that I'm
like oh my god he's trying to kill me
it's like it seems like too much work
what yeah when we started
the show like half the the news part and
video and then the second half in you
know the slideshow I was like wow the
video is a lot easier because I don't
have to have you know two hundred
pictures cut down to size finding all
those pictures and cutting them all down
to size and like putting them in where
they're supposed to go it was like a
huge pain in the ass because I don't
really like to leave I know on some of
the other like older episodes like I
would leave a picture up there for like
30 seconds 60 seconds it seems like
forever and I was like I kind of want to
switch him out every 7 to 10 seconds so
people don't get bored if they're
watching it so you know that
necessitated me finding so many more
pictures and I was like why don't we
just see the whole thing in video yeah I
will just put in photos where necessary
and then that way I just need to find a
few photos that I could put in it
relevant times and it won't be such a
huge deal right so I think we're just
gonna do that because it's it's weirdly
enough it does actually make it easier
yeah another thing that we've got going
on is we're moving out to other
platforms yeah I mean we're seeing on
YouTube obviously and if you listen to
us on you know our audio format like in
on iTunes or whatever you listen to make
a difference then it won't make a
difference to you but for those of the
those of you who watch us on YouTube we
actually decided to branch out we
thought it wouldn't hurt to like branch
out onto some other video platforms so I
made an account on vo which actually
just has our last 10 our most recent
episodes I couldn't put the movie
reviews on there because they were
giving me [ __ ] about copyright because I
guess they thought I was trying to
upload the actual movie rather than a
review of it so I just said that's too
much trouble whatever so I'll just put
the episodes up there might have been
because it was a new account though yeah
that too
and so we did that we made a account on
a [ __ ] shoot yeah and also we didn't
like I said I don't want to put the
entire back catalogue up there because
that it's gonna take forever but we have
put the most recent 10 episodes and the
most recent 10 movie reviews yeah put
the new ones on there and we're gonna
put the new ones on there subsequently
so that's we have a bit sheet account
also yeah um their search function is
still a little yeah we're gonna leave a
link we're gonna leave
linked to the [ __ ] I'll put a link in
the description description box setting
up on Facebook probably so if you want
to go you know guys know why this is
happening you know a lot of creators are
getting pretty pissed with YouTube
YouTube's policies are kind of vague and
which includes things that could be
called conspiracy theory and some of the
topics that we do might fall under some
of that but just to be safe we're
branching out into other just in case
and like I say ask me I think over time
over the next couple years YouTube is
probably gonna end up being something
really corporate almost kind of like
Netflix because cable TV lot of people
are saying that cable TV is failing and
a lot of the cable TV content producers
want to move their stuff onto a platform
other than Netflix I bet you some of
that stuff will end I think they're good
I think the corporations are going to
take over YouTube eventually so we have
to plant seeds in other garden yeah
because I mean for now like YouTube is
fine I've never had any trouble I've
never had any complaints I've never had
anything like that I don't even really
have that many shitty comments I mean
everybody has some it's YouTube yeah but
you know every morning I go through I
call it I call it pulling the weeds yeah
and I go through but I usually only get
one every couple of weeks
we just I get a stupid yeah we not mad
really troll infestations take root
because we've seen other channels
friends of ours have channels where they
just let all comments fly because I'm
like you say something stupid I'm just
playing afraid to post they're afraid to
post because I patrol and their will
jump on them and then there's all this
fighting we don't really tolerate
fighting no you know well and I don't
really tolerate negative I mean I did a
video only we're all here I don't mind
if people like have a legitimate
criticism you know some people said oh
you know the sound was kind of [ __ ] up
on them you know that's good like that
helps me because I can make the show
better but if you're just gonna be like
so like you guys are unique or something
like that then what you're not yeah
you're just being a douche [ __ ] off you
know what I mean so that's so that's
what I do but honestly we don't really
get that many because most of our
listeners are apparently yeah most of
them are good I don't know I don't get
that many and I'm just it's pretty cool
but yeah so we just figured you know how
much could it hurt to at least put our
most recent episodes on some other you
know formats so that you know we could
maybe expand an audience maybe somebody
that doesn't like you to you and maybe
they're on bitching or maybe they're on
dailymotion cuz I am very very slowly
yeah adding episodes to daily I've
always thought that dailymotion was
actually quite vanilla kind of a boring
one but it's good for watching movies
it's the second biggest video hosting
who they were these on that you know
forgotten movies that day and they don't
copyright or not they're not real anal
returns that shoot is kind of like the
Wild West it's kind of like the way
YouTube was in the early days of YouTube
but a lot of its tiering kind of beta
testing it's getting better right now
it's not fully funded comment sections
are kind of if either way like I said I
don't like the I don't search parameters
are kind of we're in the entertainment
section yeah you can find us there the
way they do they do things with hashtags
instead of keywords yeah I don't really
like it's weird but I do like one thing
about it is that a lot of the content
creators that are on [ __ ] shoot right
now are people that have gotten driven
off of youtube so what you end up with
this is a kind of a motley assortment of
real edgy material makers you know
they're just guys who are you know it
depends maybe it's political content
some of it is just movie reviews but
let's just say they're very
entertainment and very entertaining real
funny and they're real harsh a little
too edgy for YouTube you know I think of
what's his name - Steven aider you know
also the razörfist guys like that are on
there so you know they have good
provided and they have good producers
content producers just that there's not
very many of them yet there's a lot of
users though yeah a lot of users and I
feel like you know we're probably not in
danger of getting kicked off of YouTube
or anything like that but it's just that
a plan just in case but you know and
like I said it couldn't hurt to put some
of our episodes up and maybe somebody
would stumble across us that wouldn't
have other
like I said somebody that doesn't like
YouTube so you know it didn't take that
long to do so all's it takes is to get
big enough to become somebody somebody's
competition in the corporate world and
they want to drive you out of there yeah
so we're just kind of doing that just
write this in case just in case so we
just wanted that kind of like I said if
you listen to us on iTunes or whatever
this is not gonna make any difference to
you and neither will our show being
entirely in video but I'm still gonna
put audio versions up YouTube
vo dailymotion bit shoot for now yeah
dailymotion I'm still like I said
dailymotion they have a six where your
progress limits so I've been having to
cut most of our longer episodes in half
and they'll only let you upload a few
things at a time like to make sure that
you're not a spam account
so pretty much I can only upload like
four or five things a day before they're
like yeah you're kind of uploading a lot
of stuff are you spam it you know worst
thing that could happen is that if those
channels don't take off on those other
platforms they can act as kind of like
advertisements for the YouTube channel
so it's just a bigger footprint ya can
so like yeah for now from now on I'm
just gonna you know put up everything
the places I've been putting it and then
I'm just putting it in like additional
place we ever started getting shut down
on certain platforms it'll all just kind
of shift over into whatever surviving
platforms yes it just got to cover our
ass that's all yeah so we're just all
over the place and then somebody
Google's the show then they'll see all
kinds of different places where they can
watch us so that's kind of cool too and
also let's see what was our latest movie
review job you had to work you you have
to give a shout out so well yeah I was
okay just releasing you you know you
really don't you mean I have a list
right here you can't see it cuz it's
like okay I'm a glasses blind without my
glasses what see this is this is the
thing I every time we're dudes and show
on video I'm like everybody's gonna
think I wear glasses all the time
no we're glasses too because I have to
have glasses on because otherwise I
can't see the screen I can't see cuz I'm
old you know what I mean but it's all
over than Jesus I don't yeah a little
bit you are yeah but it's like I don't I
don't normally work those reason reading
glasses cuz otherwise everything is just
blurry so I'm like you know whatever but
yeah so I was gonna say yeah our latest
movie review was a boy and his dog the
very weird 1975 awesome sci-fi movie
with Don Johnson who was very young at
the time so go check that out if you
haven't already also check out our
Zazzle store at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock where we have t-shirts and a
tote to tell about the new product that
you have and this check this out you
guys remember I was talking about all
these games I was gonna do when I
started a little company called giallo
games cuz I love designing board games
and card games and stuff okay well this
is my first one and I actually got it in
the mail
cuz you have to get them before you can
put them on sale so you can check them
out but this is my first one it is
called a crimson drop on a crystal
palette
it's a giallo card it's a giallo based
card game it's kind of like a cross
between it's sort of like clue from the
back yeah it's like you I'm gonna have
to raise it because I'm gonna have to
cut this down for you we're gonna make a
commercial about yeah it's sort of like
clue crossed with Dungeons & Dragons
yeah you have there's like a director
and the director like uses the character
cards and the motive cards and the clue
cards to like construct a mystery for
the other players to solve so this is my
first one and this is my first one
that's going to go on sale and actually
by the time this episode is up these
should be on sale so if you want to go
purchase one you may but here it just
comes with a bunch of cards and here
they are they're really beautiful yeah
thank you
there's just like a bunch of cards like
that yeah they're all like these little
clues and things of that nature
I don't really know how to play this
kind of stuff this is Jenny's thing to
me it's kind of like said like that
Magic the Gathering type of thing I
don't it's not really the same premise
but you know it's like I'm doing
Dungeons & Dragons yeah it's yeah but
it's like a more complicated kind
it's an expansive game she already has
an expansion pack set up yeah and then
what I have to is that yeah and this and
a lot of the games we're gonna have this
if they
need this now this the the printing on
the top of the box is off-center but I
have fixed that so yours will not be
like that if you order one yeah this is
it expansion pack and so if you have the
regular game you have 16 characters and
a whole bunch of locations now if you
buy the expansion pack this has extra
characters extra location so you can
make the game harder you have more to
choose from and like constructing the
mystery and it makes it harder for the
players to solve it so that's kind of
where I'm at with that like I said I
have a couple other games that I've
finished but I haven't ordered proofs
yet but this will be on sale eventually
and I'm working on another one too so
new book coming games coming also when
the studio equipments in we get that new
microphone we're gonna rerecord all that
all the audio books yeah so they're all
gonna come out second editions because
the recording quality on some of them
are not kind of iffy yeah so we're gonna
clean all that up again and then after
the third we got big plans for the books
yeah we you know we're now also her my
horror fiction fiction you know it's
never been out on audio in the next year
I'm hoping to get it all out on and
we're gonna give out free samples too
cuz I have never put him on audiobook oh
yeah we'll give out free audiobook
samples to say now the faceless villain
volume 2 which is what I'm working on
now which is almost finished I was like
I said there's three more chapters and
then I just have to do the print layout
and the glossary that's all I have left
to do and so not the glossary the what
do you call it the thing where you look
up things in the back index index that's
what it's called - colosso a what the
[ __ ] am I talking about
yeah the index I have to do that I did
the bibliography on that [ __ ] already
but yeah so I have to do all that layout
now the faceless villain volume 2 that's
gonna be the first audio book that I'm
gonna do with the new microphone and
then I'm going to systematically go back
and rerecord all my other ones because
like I said that you know the old ones
that I did on audiobook they're fine but
I would rather we need better so yeah I
would rather redo them like with a
better because we gotta get him
we'll probably put them out in order of
popularity in terms of sales figures yes
so I'll probably do I'll do faceless
fill in two first cuz that's the new one
then I'll go back and do faceless ville
and one then I'll do unseen hands and
then I'll go back and do the shorter
ones yeah actually we probably knock out
Mammoth Mountain then the the Mara books
and then we'll do your nonfiction or do
my fiction yeah your fiction because my
fiction has never been on audiobook just
because I haven't had hatreds and
subscribers will get a certain amount of
free samples of the new yeah I always do
and we'll give them out and you guys
they give me 25 codes for free audio
samples that you can you don't have an
Amazon account we'll give it to you oh
and also another thing I want to say too
is that audible they started a new
because I don't know if you guys knew if
you know anything about audible but for
creators they have a bounty program if
you if you get somebody to sign up for
audible yeah and your book is the first
one that they purchase then the Creator
gets a $50 yeah we get a bounty on
recruiting you into already booked right
now but what they started doing now was
they kind of changed it where now it's
not so much that you have to be like the
first book that they purchased but you
have to purchase it through a special
link like there's a particular link that
you have to give them and if you
purchase it through that link then I get
$75 yeah yeah so I actually posted the
link on my blog all the links on my blog
got us a pal fire yeah if you want to
get under audio for the first time then
buy one of her books make sure you
probably best to contact her directly on
Facebook to it and she can walk it
through the process
yeah because 75 dollars man a pop just
for an audiobook that helped us out a
lot yeah it really yeah and then almost
a good service yeah and it's you know
it's really good it's you know they give
you a very large percentage of your
sales especially if you do what I do and
record your own audiobooks so I don't
have to like split it with anybody which
is nice but yeah so it's I I always like
to using it's very easy to use yeah and
working you know this
that this is good it's good I'm glad
they did that we're constantly trying to
work to give you a better quality
product yeah yeah like I said so that's
why we've spent all that money getting
all the upgrading all our equipment and
stuff like that because we've been
talking about wanting to do that and you
know you guys I mean I have to say you
know our HR patreon people and our you
know you people that give us money on
the shows for you yet has really like
kind of come through for us a lot and
you know we really want to make the best
show we can possibly make it so we said
we're just gonna bite the bullet we're
gonna yeah we're gonna upgrade
everything we're gonna buy all-new most
of our listeners are ongoing listeners
they'll go back and start with episode
one and work all the way through it so
sometimes when we have these big intros
like this in the show you have some
people that will click off immediately
if they don't know who we are we don't
really care about them yeah we are
trying to grow our own audience base and
we use that audio space to give you free
ebooks you guys have put reviews that
helps us launch books in on Amazon yes
and you know plus we enjoy doing this
show we like to do the show we like all
that yeah we bring it with you guys so
we just do these shows yeah and like I
said we wanted the best stuff we could
possibly make sense right
we just wanted I got I got my favorite
YouTube shows that I watched too so
that's kind of what inspires me to go
you know when to get we need to improve
our lives the way things go and I want
to have a good show
yeah you know that's that's exactly what
I was thinking I mean you know my
favorite YouTube [ __ ] well that's blame
society welcome to the basement and
we're gonna get that guarantee that's
why I want bare and board games to do
this if you guys are watching that would
be really cool I'm a big fan so it's
like they actually yeah they actually
are the ones that inspired me to get
back into designing board games cuz I
used to do it a long time ago cuz I just
liked it and I never really did anything
with it but when I started watching them
like man I really need to get back into
that [ __ ] so I started doing it again
but yeah so oh and also speaking of
patreon we have a new patron named
Christopher hi welcome to the show
thanks Chris Berg and also I have to
shout out Elizabeth who is our patron
before but she actually upped her
support this week okay yeah yeah after
we complained yeah we're not sure our
thousand dollar
chuckles you don't worry though we will
open up another chance yeah we want to
do we're not well we're not opening
another channel board doing another
weekly another weekly show yeah yeah
we're gonna do another like a third
weekly show it'll probably come out on
Sunday I want to say I'll probably put
it up on Sundays and call it time
machine thirteen time machine thirteen
it's gonna be like a retro show you guys
talking about
we're gonna be it's gonna be kind of
broad range we're gonna talk about like
stuff we remember from our childhood
stuff that's not there anymore ministry
that kind of stuff yeah why things
happen certain ways I was thinking along
the lines of something kind of like a
dead the cross doing like a dead mall
yeah cuz I love series I like those and
and some of the kind of like nostalgia
shows like talking about blockbuster and
talking about you know what what went
wrong with blockbuster also kind of like
show kind of like company man mixed yeah
I like that too and I also want to put
in stuff about you know old technology
that we grew up with toys that I
remember from my youth because I kind of
don't want really cool music with it
yeah maybe like some vaporwave music at
certain times yeah so that's what we're
kind of planning on so once we got
visuals that's one of our goals like
when we get to a thousand dollars a
month on patreon we're actually going to
start a third weekly show that will be
all about that it'll be like retrospect
like 70's and 80's type stuff maybe 90s
but I was I was kind of old by then I
graduated from high school in 1990 now
it's what's done we're done yes that was
the news you have to do past his word
okay so do news now we're gonna do knit
this isn't tech I mean it's not
technically news okay but I wanted to do
because we're doing a show about the
black dahlia which is probably one of
the most famous cold cases in American
history I wanted to focus on another
cold case that maybe somebody out there
could help solve cuz this wasn't as long
ago as the Black Dahlia so maybe there's
still a possibility and I also focused
on this one because one I saw a couple
news stories come out and recently
because they've just reopened it and two
because it happened in Cocoa Beach which
is not that far from here that's in
Florida so it's probably only 50 miles
from here I want to say I'm not entirely
sure it's over on the coast
so this was a case that took place 23
years ago in 1994 and this is the murder
of Amy Gellert now her whole entire
family was attacked but she was the only
one that subsequently died from her
injuries what happened was apparently a
guy broke into the family's house and
was stealing a bunch of stuff from her
parents and he had a lead he had a gun
and a knife and he was like stabbing
them and stuff and she came home in the
middle she came home from church and she
basically she gets out of the car and
she's in the driveway and then she sees
her stepfather who was named Bob Layton
and he comes running out of the front
door of the house and he's just covered
with blood and then behind him this
guy's like running after him in a black
ski mask and he has a dagger and a gun
right yeah so yeah so apparently they
find out
so the dad's been stabbed and the girl's
mother has been stabbed her mother's
name is bunny and she's also been
stabbed now they both survived but for
whatever reason this guy just comes
running out of the house and just starts
wailing on this poor girl Amy who was
just she she was like in her 20s and
just like starts stabbing her stabbing
her and then she tries to get to another
house but she actually ended up dying
hmm now they what you resist this was
1994 so and as I said it happened in
Cocoa Beach
so they've the last year or two they've
really been trying to push to solve this
because they think they have a couple of
suspects they're like see there were two
weird things about it in the in the
panic the guy dropped a magazine out of
the pistol now they were able to trace
this particular pistol all it says is
that the pistol was traced to like a
prop pistol that was like used in movies
and like she wasn't real so I guess not
because it seems like the people were
they were stabbed not shot he was just
using an intimidation tool right now the
knife
even though um you know obviously that's
weird the mom and dad versus they lived
now the guy was wearing a ski mask so
they didn't know what he looked like but
they said the knife that he had they
couldn't see the hilt but they said that
one part of it was like really ornate
and it has there's a drawing of it and
if you're watching the video I'll put
like a little drawing of the video of
the what the knife looks like because
it's a pretty distinctive looking like a
really ordinary dagger you know it's
weird is that he dropped a real magazine
magazine out on the ground they had
found it that wouldn't have been a clue
yeah this real real pistols are more
common than fake pistols well see that's
what I was thinking rare here at what I
was thinking that's why probably I think
they might be able to solve this [ __ ]
just because that's such a weird yeah
you don't saying to like take to a crime
scene and that's like you know it's
unusual like you said if it was just a
regular pistol magazine I'd never be
able to find it cause it's like oh yeah
right
so yeah they do have a sketch of part of
the dagger that the the parents saw so
they're kind of hoping they said they
have two suspects one of them is named
Dominic Kanika kanika something like
that he was a short-order cook at the
time and the other suspect they have his
name scott manley who apparently had
supposed to he either had a date or was
going to a party or something with Amy
that night but then he cancelled it and
then she subsequently got murdered on
that day now both of these guys are in
prison for other things so I'm kind of
wondering I don't know if they if they
have any DNA evidence I don't think
there is that they could match to one of
these two people but these are the two
strongest suspects like I said they're
both in prison on other charges but
those are the two main guys that they're
looking at and like I said this just
happened in 1994 so you know and the
parents are still alive you know they
were attacked also but they survived
their injuries so they're kind of hoping
that they will
be able to find that the person that
killed their daughter that just ran out
of the house and just like stabbed her
to death in the driveway of their
[ __ ] house I mean Jesus Christ so you
know if anybody out there knows anything
about this like I said it happened in
Cocoa Beach in 1994 in March of 84
yeah it's for a man Jesus Christ you
know running around with alligators
throwing them in Wendy's an alligator
why we got to have him on as a guest
yeah he seemed actually pretty chill I
saw me look funny man it's like okay
baby seems like he's like yeah you got
me I was running around a convenience
store with an alligator I don't know
what I was doing I what else you got
that's uh that's pretty much it I just
wanted to do like a crime story and like
I said I wanted to do a cold case
because of the black dahlia is like kind
of the ultimate American cold case that
I've probably at this point I don't
think they're ever gonna solve it but
you know we'll talk about it but we'll
talk about it and so that'll be now you
can do the past tense news that was the
news [ __ ] that news because it's gone
I'm sorry okay get like a real news song
yeah put anyway we get to do studio I
want yeah III probably sing it okay I'll
sing it in studio nipped over and then
you yeah that's a good idea yeah I I was
kind of thinking about how I don't know
like I said um how many of you watched
it's my favorite YouTube show which is
welcome to the basement but they do like
a little satellite show called unboxing
where they open all of their mail and
stuff and Matt the main guy on the show
he's been doing something he calls the
Ford report he's watching all the movies
by with that director something Ford
what's the thing that does all this
point no no that does all those westerns
and so and I thought the funny thing was
the he psycho I need a theme song for
this it is like this really cheesy like
Casio like Mario Brothers these like
it's like every time I hear it I crack
up cuz I'm just like it's not what you
would expect you would expect it to be
something like you know are like western
sounding but it's not he just like did
this totally
cheesy and it's hilarious so I think
that's kind of what I'm gonna do with
the news story I'm gonna buy you can you
can sing it and then I'll do it like
this [ __ ] and then I'll put this
super cheesy music or you could do it oh
you should do it like man said I could
yeah you should do it like it do it like
a 70s porn theme good do anything that
would be that would be really cool I
think that's what's up okay
I think that's what we should do yeah so
that's that would be something for you
guys to look forward to all right so I
think that'll do it for our opening
segment as long as it was so now we're
gonna be back with you with we're gonna
be back in a little bit to talk about
the black dolls
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why it's so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day that this house is and will
continue to be on to Buddy Ginny's got
some new shirt designs up four of them
really good ones to Atlanta Ripper who
put Bello in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job Atum really fun
making Jenny they were very fun and
thank you very much I think they came
out right yeah it really good they're
very high-quality shirts Jenny and I
we're sure our own shirts at certain
times when we're trying to put spotlight
on ourselves and you can put a spotlight
on yourselves if you go ahead and pick
up on these shirts today you guys are
gonna love them makes in the description
WWL comm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out
our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
at old ones but these ones are awesome
and you should check them out they're
also available in women's cut they look
really cute JT's got some so thank you
go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so here we are talking about
probably one of the best-known American
unsolved murders yeah
initiate the Black Dahlia and I'll tell
you up for beginner this Black Dahlia
dis sucking Kayla here man it's smell I
had to go get some more it smells
terrible
I don't get some more man this thing's
got me wrapped up here I'm in the
presence of the of the Aztec gods right
now wow I'm getting ready to be taken to
I'm being getting ready to be taking the
top of a big old Mayan pyramid
sacrificed our cool God they're gonna be
down the steps to show you this [ __ ]
just like an apocalypse right here
almost sponsor this right now okay hey
if makers mark tequila wants to sponsor
this yeah I'm sponsoring this this is
this is actually sam's club
kela we get all our liquor from Sam's
Club god this stuff is good man we're
classy like that well hey man you're the
prices are good I just probably that's
cheap yeah it's the Valcke is exactly
like Grey Goose 111 bucks for $13 and
then this one is like $30 for a bottle I
think it was $30 wasn't it oh is it no I
think it's only 20 20 dollars bond 5 $25
and see the beautiful part about it is
is this is a business expense so we
write this [ __ ] off on our taxes it is
the business expense yeah I've got a
have it man it fuels the show that's
what I mean the show is not as an
alcohol-fueled program the shows not as
funny when we're sober that's all I'm
saying we're not drunk drunk it's just
you know we need a little bit of fun
yeah we need a little bit of social
lubrication as maybe I'm Bob all great
artists we're like that throughout the
70s yeah cocaine [ __ ] our Devon eases
alcohol I'm just saying I'm a writer I'm
a game designer I'm a graphic designer
it's like you do that [ __ ] yeah I mean
you know I'm not a big drug person but
I'm not a drunk but it helps yeah
say okay now now okay so let's talk
about the black dolly you know about
this case kind of yeah thing about this
case I feel like it's probably it's
probably one of the best note he's won
because it was never solved which that
always helps too because it was like
super gruesome it's kind of like the
Jack the Ripper things it's like Jack
the Ripper he was a serial killer he
only you know only killed five women
that they know of but because the
murders were so gruesome and they never
caught him and no one ever saw him so it
was kind of like that so I feel like the
Black Dahlia Murder is kind of falling
under that there was really no motive
she was cut in half for Christ's sake
yeah plus like a lot of other a smiley
face book yeah like there were a lot of
other mutilations also not just that I
mean that's bad enough but I'm just
saying there was a bunch of other [ __ ]
too and you know and and over the years
it has been fictionalized so many times
like James Ellroy wrote kind of a
fictionalized account of it Brian
DePalma made a movie in 2006 called the
Black Dahlia which actually I remember
saw it seeing in the theater I liked it
is a little overwrought I mean you know
it's Brian De Palma but it's not it's
very loosely based on what really
happened and I think that a lot of [ __ ]
has a lot of like weird rumors and
speculation about her as a person which
I think kind of does her a disservice
because she was just like a regular girl
and then like there's all this info she
was a hooker and she was a lesbian she
was you know she had a weird she had a
weird vagina like it was like there's
all these like [ __ ] weird rumors
about it's like she's just a normal
regular seen chick girl it's live scene
chicken california you know she was from
Boston she moved out to California maybe
she wanted to be an actress maybe she
was just working as a waitress it's like
she wasn't a prostitute she wasn't she
there was nothing glamorous right so
there was like nothing weird about her
particularly she was just a normal
person so I you know I kind of wanted to
get into that too because I feel like
they you know a lot of the movies and
stuff about her kind of makes her look
like trash yeah or like she deserve
somehow yeah she's just a regular chips
yo sister regular gorge regular
California chick for the scene at that
time right that's all she was that's it
yeah that's all she was and also I think
and it must be said too that I think the
reason that people still remember this
case too is because she was a very
beautiful girl and she was very
distinctive looking so you know with
that that's always kind of helps I hate
to say it but when when the victims are
good they're good you know people girls
just forgotten I know it's sad but it's
true
well and I think we kind of went into
this too and a little bit on our Atlanta
Ripper show where it's like you know
when the victims are you know working
class black girls yeah they're kind of
forgotten what really cares honestly
yeah but demographic so says do with
marketing yeah you can easily market a
product to a mainstream America if it
involves a white person especially back
in those days yeah when white people
were more of a majority yeah and I think
that definitely have been near more it's
not as racial as people want to read
into it's more about marketing and you
know and I think the thing too is that
really nobody there's really no motive I
feel like there's no motive for her to
have been murdered this viciously yeah I
mean for somebody to do what they did to
her even though a lot of it was done
after she was dead it's like why the
just the motivation for just kind of
kills me and Plus like I said in the
ensuing years there have been a lot of
like you know weird rumors about who
killed her and stuff there even somebody
talked in the beginning how does this go
down well listen the start from the
beginning obviously her real name is
Elizabeth Short who summoned in 1947 now
she was originally from Boston as I said
so it's post-war right Calla from
California partially yeah California
Mississippi Brazil I was moving around
everywhere yeah they're from Long Beach
California I was actually born in Long
Beach left when I was about 12 in the
40s California was very the area they're
talking about was actually kind of rural
by today's standards it was a developing
part of the country yeah it was in a way
a lot like the way Florida
is now and I will tell people this here
in Florida they look at me like I'm
[ __ ] crazy
I'm from California California was very
Florida like for a long time it didn't
it wasn't metropolitan until kind of
Mott the modern area era and what
Florida was like is that it was kind of
like a bunt at his country mostly with
some suburbs and small cities one of
them being Los Angeles the other one
being like Sacramento San Francisco the
rest of the stuff was very suburban and
very country yeah but what it allowed
you to do because it was kind of because
it wasn't very restrictive and it was a
big state it allowed for good social
scenes including actors you know I mean
they could get by with on a very small
paycheck go to good clubs and live in
small places you know they give him Bela
Lugosi lived in a little bitty place
towards the end of his career and it was
a fun place it was not the California
you would know today so you have to put
that in perspective yeah
Cal California and 47 was suburban yeah
yeah largely I mean it's kind of like
here nat well and it was a tight knit
air group yeah people it was more like a
scene well and like I said the thing
about Elizabeth Short was that she was
originally from Boston her dad actually
for a job built miniature golf courses
yeah but he lost most of his money
during the stock market crash now one of
the weird things about her family
background is that for a long time they
thought that her dad had committed
suicide because like they found his car
and they never found his body and all
this other stuff so like the mom and all
the kids you know including Elizabeth
Short like kind of moved on thinking he
was dead and then many years later the
dad cousin was like yeah sorry about
that
I faked my death and now I have a new
life with like a new wife and new kids
and stuff so that in part is why one of
the reasons why Elizabeth Short like
moved to California now she had a lot of
health problems when she was younger
like with their young son
Titus and things like that so they told
her well you need to move to a warmer
climate because that's what they usually
told you to do back then go to a warmer
climate it's not yeah so she actually
lived in Miami for a little while and
back and forth so and eventually when
she was older she went to live with her
father in California and she actually
hadn't seen a Burberry long time she
thought he was dead which must've been
pretty weird but yeah so she moved back
out there now most of the things that
are situated aspiring actress which
maybe she was there were actually if you
look on Google and I'll put some of them
in the in the show there are actually
like a lot of photos of her that looked
like not professional
you know headshots or anything like that
but they look like you know this is
something you would send to a casting
you know yeah she was a very very pretty
girl rate model but you know I thought
she was a very pretty girl she um
she's very distinctive looking like I
said she have very very black hair and
she always had it's weird because after
she died one of the autopsy report was
talking about how her all her teeth were
were rotten or decayed but it doesn't
look like that from the photos now she
so I don't know if she was an aspiring
actress she doesn't have any acting
credits she apparently never got any
acting jobs that we know there's no wire
teeth were not that I know of it's like
it could have been that or maybe she
just wasn't I mean maybe it was some
kind of nutritional issue maybe she had
grown up kind of poor I don't know like
I said because you know she was quite
young when her dad when they thought her
dad committed suicide yeah so her mom
was kind of like forced to take a job
like raise the kids on her own and all
this other [ __ ] cuz the dad faked his
death and abandoned them which I thought
was kind of strange but yeah so
eventually she ended up in California
like I said and she was working as she
was doing waitressing secretarial CAD
type of work [ __ ] like that now one
thing that I read like I said it seems
like they always want to show was she
was a prostitute or she was even some of
the newspaper reports that time she was
prowling up and
where do they call it would Boulevard I
think well it was because I mean William
Randolph Hearst owned a lot of the
larger newspapers in Los Angeles at the
old journalism and yeah they just wanted
to make it more salacious they even
changed the description of the outfit
that she was last seen wearing to makes
it it was the sheer black they it was a
business suit it was a black business
suit is what it was that's what she was
last seen wearing when she got dropped I
was nothing [ __ ] nothing like that she
was not like I said she wasn't a hooker
she was an anything right now one thing
that she did kind of do though she was
very popular she did hang out in like
hotel bars she did like you know date
men and stuff I mean she you know she
was a single girl that's what you did
yeah and honestly she didn't have a lot
of money so sometimes she would go out
on dates with dudes and like hey they'd
buy her dinner and she was like hey free
meal that's a lot of girls did that
especially their late eighties right
it's like why wouldn't you do it so it's
like she like I said she wasn't a hooker
or anything like that but you know she
was kind of like getting some food where
she could get it which you know you
can't blame the girl for doing that so
at this point so this so she's been
doing this and kind of hanging out there
not for you know kind of a long time
she's there in January 1947 now the last
time that she's seen they think was
January 9th 1947 now she had been in San
Diego visiting some friends and she was
there with someone named Robert red
manly who some sources say was a friend
some sources say she was dating him he
was married but you know I so I don't
know what the truth of that matter is
like I said I don't like to besmirch
people's forties was common yes so she
could have very well been it's like it's
not that marriages were kind of economic
and political back dad and guys [ __ ]
around yeah and got away with it so he
was evidently the last person to see her
alive and this was on january 9th he
dropped her off at the Biltmore Hotel
and now and then at that point there was
like a missing week because you know
some people claim to have seen her
during this week some people you know
it's like it's it's kind of sketchy
where she was during all that time but
basically she turned up dead on the
morning of January 15 1947 now Betty
burr singer who was walking around this
neighborhood lament park with her kid
this was a largely it was kind of a
neighborhood but was like marked largely
undeveloped at this point she was
walking around there kid and and I've
written enough true crime to know that
every time somebody sees a body just
laying on the side of the road they
always say I thought it was a broken
mannequin they all say that I've seen
dead bodies they do they don't yeah
really so that well that's not that yeah
because that's not the first thing you
would think of yeah and that was
definitely the case in this case that's
what she thought she thought it was a
broken mannequin yeah
it was Elizabeth Short now she had been
sliced in half cleanly at the lumbar
vertebra her her entire body was white
she had been drained completely a blood
her body had been cleaned with gasoline
her that means something yeah well and
there was some other [ __ ] about that too
so also her mouth whoever did it cut her
mouth from here the sides of her mouth
to her ears which is called a Glasgow
smile which if any of you are from
Glasgow I don't know why it's called
that I don't know it's just kind of like
that Columbian necktie thing is it a
Colombian necktie yeah yeah yeah you
guys yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
but yeah so this is called a Glasgow
smile when they cut from the corners of
your mouth to your ears she had that her
intestines had
tucked under her buttocks some actually
later sources said that she even burned
with cigarettes but that's actually not
on the autopsy report now right now
something that I did see from some
sources that somebody allegedly had torn
out all of her pubic hair by hand I
don't know I don't know if that's true
or not I don't know maybe they can tell
now some of them some of the sources
also said they know that she didn't do
that
why would yes sure yeah that's the thing
you know they might have plucks back
down they might shave who knows also her
anal opening was dilated which made them
it's it led them to believe that she had
been raped but there was no sperm
present but I'm like yeah but it doesn't
need to yeah but it doesn't need to be a
dick to be rape you know rape they could
have raped him somebody like a bottle or
something yeah but when a person dies
they lose the ability to you know yes so
she was just laying in this undeveloped
neighborhood now they think that she had
been dead for about ten hours at this
point when they found the body
the only other clues that they found now
she also had a bunch of cuts all
everybody liked on her thighs and her
buds and like some of her some of there
were like chunks of her flesh that had
been like cut off really were things of
that nature I think even like I don't
know if it was like her nipples and
stuff have been cut off as if I meet
somebody not it's not say anything in
the autopsy report well it's like I said
sources are kind of this conflict
there's conflict in the sources and she
had also been posed like her legs had
been opened her arms had been put behind
her head that's typical and think yes so
it's obviously somebody wanted her found
and wanted her to be found in that
particular fashion so this was a
fetishistic
killing obviously because you know they
had left it in that way so the only
clues they found at the scene
they found a heel print
they also found a couple of tire tracks
there was a cement sack that had a
little bit of watery blood on it or in
it but that was pretty much it
there was a cement sack near her yes
just an empty sack so I don't know if
that says in the trunk so that might
have been something that was in the
killer's car or they had transported the
body in that or whatever I'm not really
sure so yes so that that was kind of
that and like I said this is probably
why this case is so famous because she
was she was basically cut in half at the
point where where you wouldn't have
where would be easiest right to bisect a
body so there was some knowledge so they
are kind of thinking even from the
beginning they're thinking this is
somebody that has some surgical
knowledge probably because how would you
know otherwise to cut at this particular
point and like I said somebody had
drained all the body all the blood out
there was no blood in the body and they
had washed it with gasoline so yeah that
means there was something all in the
body that they wanted to wash off I
wonder maybe if there was some kind of
makeup or applied or some kind of paint
applied to photograph the body maybe
yeah man that was washed off to hide the
evidence
it's a weird I mean it makes me wonder
was this body used in a photo shoot oh I
never thought of that
yeah and actually I kind of want to get
into a little bit later because when
we're talking about the whole dr. George
Hodel thing and like how he was friends
with me way happy who was a big who was
a famous photographer he was a
photographer no not George Hodel but he
was friends with Man Ray who is a very
famous photographer named Man Ray has a
very famous photograph called the
Minotaur which is of a naked woman's
torso and she has her arms up like that
just like black dahlias were and so a
lot of people like I don't know the kind
of black with all the adventure yeah
quick to mind it seemed a little odd
that it why would you have to wash an
entire body and gas
in an Arab he watched all her stuff in
gasoline and they did that before the
era of DNA okay so he's not trying to
hide DNA he's trying to hide something
else that was put on their fingerprints
I don't even think so
maybe makeup I don't know like I said
it's this is the [ __ ] weird a weird
ass case yeah so honestly a body was
stored into some kind of a gasoline
inside of a gasoline container for a
while well it wasn't a while because
they thought she'd only been dead for
about ten hours before they found the
body so she must have been killed and
most of the mutilations obviously being
cut in half and all the other stuff most
of the mutilations have been postmortem
she actually died from trauma to her
head from like they beat her around the
head and just basically killed her that
way doctor out and strangled her or
something no they didn't strangle her it
was just bad injuries yeah and blood
loss she didn't so all of the all of the
injuries to her body the very famous
injuries were actually happened after
she was dead so here is the [ __ ] up
part so they identified her pretty much
immediately because she had her
fingerprints were on file not only
because she had applied for a job at a
nearby army base but also because she
had been arrested like seven months to a
year before just for underage drinking
it wasn't like a big deal but yes so
that's why there's mug shots of her like
on if you look on google there's mug
shots of her it wasn't like shouldn't I
couldn't do anything horrible it was she
was just underage drinking at a bar so
they had her fingerprints on file so
they were able to identify her pretty
much immediately now here's a shitty
thing as I said William Randolph Hearst
who owned one or two largest newspapers
in Los Angeles airing his house yeah
yeah went to her spouse wait a minute
now I've seen it I've seen pictures of
it oh my god it's like a Roman Palace
that guy was kind of a piece of [ __ ]
that I've read I've read a couple um
about his house his houses fancy really
nice house back during the era of the
American robber baron oh yeah those
[ __ ] were just like they were
like gods on the earth they're like
something out of damn Prometheus yeah
yeah so this is what they did they
wanted the scoop on this so bad
reporters from one of the Hearst
Newspapers called Elizabeth Schwartz
mother Phoebe back in Boston and said
your daughter won a beauty contest and
like got all this personal information
out of the mother with the mother
thinking oh yay Elizabeth won a beauty
contest after they get all this
information out of her they're like oh
by the way actually she got murdered
and then they were like hey we'll pay
your airfare out here if you promise to
talk to us first and not the police so
you know that's nice 1947 so yeah that's
that's what happened there mmm and like
I said the newspaper reports at the time
tried to make it much more salacious
than it was they were always oh she had
this sheer black blouse and she was like
a hooker and she was prowling up and
down like I said she had on a normal
black business suit like most women
would wear yeah in 1947 was just a
normal outfit she wasn't like cruising
around or anything like that
so yeah well liable laws weren't an
existing back then true you know that
they're not existing anymore if you look
at the garbage tear media that you have
online right now they call it they'll
tell you they'll say anything about you
well the thing is even if the laws are
in place it's like you don't have the
money to see you bring up the shoes
Alvar to bring a loss in helping and
helping you sue a web site that doesn't
have any money yeah that's what I mean
there might as well not be along like
what are you gonna do about it right and
the thing is it's like once the
information is out there everybody's
gonna remember the first thing they hear
they're not gonna remember the
correction that's just human psychology
that's how that works that's why when
newspapers print retractions it's like
it hardly ever works because people
remember the big [ __ ] on the on the
front page they don't remember the
little retraction that you did to talk
about fake news now fake news now has
none have anything on the on the era of
the
journalism they just made [ __ ] up back
there they made [ __ ] I mean they do that
now - I'm not saying that but - super
brazen yeah so you gotta watch like I
said you you braid about true crime like
I write it and I'm trying to like get
some you know good information media's a
bunch of lies but you know you can get
newspapers from the time but you're
really gonna read a whole bunch of
different ones like to kind of get it
because you're gonna get different
versions you try not to I try to like
you yeah so okay evidently so this
happens right now there were some there
was some kind of [ __ ] - about some
zodiac type [ __ ] here - which I think
maybe a lot of people don't know about
this about the black jelly a case but
apparently the alleged killer
did kind of taunt the police I didn't
know about that and said you see that's
I didn't know about that and kind of
send them sort of random note sort of
messages and [ __ ] like that January 21st
which was you know about a week after
the body was found a person who said
that they killed Elizabeth Short they
called the editor of the Los Angeles
Examiner and they said oh you guys have
done such a good job covering the murder
you know your paper is done such a good
job of covering the murder he's like I'm
gonna turn myself in eventually but I'm
gonna let the police chase me more cuz I
like that I guess and he says to the
editor he says I'm gonna send you to
prove to you that I'm the person that
killed her I'm gonna send you some
mementos from Beth short he says on the
phone three days later a manila envelope
arrives and it had been actually they
found it at the post office but it had
been addressed to the los angeles
examiner and other los angeles
newspapers and the it was it was done
like a ransom note it was like cut and
pasted [ __ ] out of other newspapers and
[ __ ] like that and on the
envelope it said here is dahlias
belongings letter to follow inside the
envelope was Elizabeth shorts birth
certificate a bunch of business cards
that she had had on her from various
people that she knew some photographs of
her some names written on a piece of
paper and there was an address book in
there and this was kind of a significant
clue there's an address book in there
that the name mark Hanson was embossed
on the cover so obviously mark Hanson
they said well we have to figure out who
this is because he's like a main suspect
now it turned out that mark Hanson was
like he owned kind of a sketchy
nightclub in the area Elizabeth Short
was a friend of his she had been staying
with him and his wife or girlfriend just
as a paying boarder he was actually
investigated quite a bit but they
couldn't really find any evidence to
suggest any one couple would not have
been in that information right and
that's yeah and that's what I mean I
mean I whatever that guy's sent back he
had and mark actually said she's like oh
well I just had that address book in my
house and I had never used it so
Elizabeth just took it he made him
culpable right that's what I'm doing so
I kind of don't feel like investigating
so I kind of buy a mark Hanson story
it's like well I just had an empty
address book in my house with my name on
it you know I had them printed and I
never used it so she just used it
because she was living here and she
needed one so I gave her one so but yeah
so but whoever sent this stuff to the
newspaper obviously knew her I don't
know if it was her killer but he
obviously knew her because he had all of
her [ __ ] yeah so he did send it he
killed her so yeah he killed her he
killed her and whatever he sent back
there with whatever he sent to them
whatever that that whatever those items
contained that contained no information
that you could trace it back to him
right that's all I wouldn't know because
that would be dumb if you just like an
address book oh ho hey here's my name
yeah come get me yeah that would have
been really dumb but yeah so they were
trying to get fingerprints off the
envelope and [ __ ] like that but then you
know they were like well then we don't
know who else touched this on the way
so we can't you know it was 1947 what
are you gonna do you you can't [ __ ]
do that she don't know how to feel
touched it and Trump already at the
point now where I'm gonna tell you
something what are you gonna tell me
this wasn't a serial killer no it
couldn't have been probably not I feel
like it was someone that knew it was
somebody that knew her and this is a
one-of-a-kind crime if it was a serial
killer wouldn't have been known as the
Black Dahlia case it would have been
known as a [ __ ] group of cases this is
a one-time kill and it was some guy that
knew her had contact with her and he did
this to her and then he taunted the
police over it and it was a
one-of-a-kind killing because if if he
had killed more it would have fit this
same pattern and then those homicides
would have fallen into the same lot with
this one yeah I wouldn't know it as the
Black Dahlia case he would notice too
something or other murders yeah like
there were some other one-time Kasem I'm
thinking there were some other cases
that took place in the area and would
have dragged on those cases yeah like
that case to this one there were some
other cases that took place in the area
at the time that some people thought
were related but none of them were
really that similar now the only case
offender would have made sure to link
all these cases together he's already
talking to the police
had he killed more of them he would have
said oh by the way he would have pulled
oh yeah he would have killed a Zodiac
and then I can you've been like the
Zodiac killer and been like hey I killed
this one now and the other one might
come catch me so this was this is a
novice killer this is a one-time event
some people have tried yeah I know you
are
yeah well the only serial killer that
well one of the few serial killers that
have been linked to this case because
Peter Morello who was one of the if he
watched our show about the Cleveland
torso murders you'll know who Peter
Marlow is he was one of the main
investigators on that case and he was
actually trying to establish a link
between the Cleveland torso murders and
the black dahlia murder be just because
the mo was very very similar because if
you'll remember the Cleveland torso
murderer also enjoy
cutting up his victims in a similar
fashion I'm going to go back to what I
was saying before in the profiling if it
was the same offender he would have
taken pains to tell the authorities this
so there's hella limpid this is a one
time killer he gloated over it and then
stopped from one reason or another maybe
he was killed maybe he killed himself
maybe he wasn't able to continue maybe
his life changed in some way or another
and he wasn't he continued something
like that could have been this is a
one-time event
he got off on it for awhile and then
started to regret it
or something changed in his life and he
said I don't want to be involved in that
anymore I've got too much to lose
something like that which seems a little
odd someone that would go to the trouble
of killing someone cutting them in half
do we model all of this [ __ ] that he did
and then leaving it where obviously
someone would find it may have been
something just as simple as he did this
gloated over it and then met a girl he
liked her normalised married her later
on and there's no way he wanted her to
get involved in that [ __ ] again because
he lose this one something like that
that kind of [ __ ] scares me because I do
that you don't know serial killers get
girlfriends serial killers get married
oh I know yeah that kind of scares me so
I might have been something like because
what if the girlfriend the wife doesn't
know and then you find out later oh
really
killers I wanna mean sis I'm sorry some
killers have the ability to stop I know
by the FBI by the FBI definition you
have to kill three yes in this same
fetishes yeah and it's just it's sort of
fashion sure if you stop after the first
one you're technically not a serial not
a serial killer
so this may have been a one-off thrill
killing and for some reason the fetish
didn't hold yeah it didn't take root
this might be more common than we
realized
right and it's just not as studied
because they're not a serial killer
right they don't do it again because
there are a lot of
unsolved murders that have real weird
you know a lot more about it than I do I
have a latest I have a layman's
understanding of this there's a lot of
[ __ ] like this yeah I have a layman's
understanding of this case and that's
what I'm gonna tell you right now based
on what I'm hearing from you but go
ahead go ahead
okay so the same day that this package
of stuff like arrived at this at the Los
Angeles examiner's office somebody also
reported that there was a purse and some
black suede shoes and they were on top
of a garbage can in this alley like not
far from where Elizabeth Schwartz body
was found
now these things had also been washed in
gasoline and Redman Lee who was the last
person to see Elizabeth Short alive he
had driven her from San Diego back to
her house in Los Angeles they had kind
of been dating off and on and he
actually helps the police identify he's
like yeah that's her stop so somebody
left it I think it was about two miles
away like in an alley about two miles
from where they washing it in gasoline
yeah which which in 47 would have been
overkill you know what I mean he doesn't
even know about the existence of the
[ __ ] DNA although I heard they were
killing it he's making sure there's no
way to find him is it this is his first
one yeah because serial killers tend to
get lazy and they don't give a [ __ ] they
just leave the body there is it though
because seriously I watched this [ __ ]
this short safety film from the 40s or
the early 50s they used to wash wash
clothes in gasoline like dry cleaning
time got me you got me yeah but the
thing is so it wasn't that unusual like
oh it'll wash everything they used to
use gasoline for hair pomade yeah but it
was a different gasoline I know it was
but I'm just saying it was so it did not
have the detergents that you would have
today no and it didn't have all the
additives it wouldn't burn you up as bad
as it would today it did though because
earlier it was oily ER this film that I
saw was from like I said it was late 40s
or early 50s
and it was great and it was a safety
film about hey if you're washing your
clothes in gasoline as everyone does
yeah back in the day then be sure not to
blow yourself up
right it was one of those type of things
and they had like this housewife and she
was like washing up clothes merrily and
gasoline and then she set herself on
fire and she died in her family it was a
different gasoline go I know it's not
the same guy than you have day and I'm
gonna tell you a story
okay I worked with it when I was young
my effect got out of the army I worked
with an old man who was in his 80s all
right now Oh Jimmy yeah you told me that
and Jimmy would talk about how delicious
it was to deep-fry whole chickens Oh in
motor oils like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
because whether it was a different motor
oil we had yeah I was like ruining it
and he was this it was a different motor
oil you ever do his voice it was a
different motor oil we had that day you
could deep-fry in it
and I was like no way it is like you
could batter a chicken and you could
drop it in five gallons of motor oil and
it was sizzle and pop and when it came
out of there there be no oil at all in
the batter and it was like really
because it wouldn't absorb there's some
weird scene he was in the flavor was
good and I said this is motiroti good
shell mobile shell and mobile
we even had brands me yeah yeah that
they were cooking in it you could not
believe it you couldn't do that today
not with the detergent I tell you what
though if somebody made a discus and he
was so thick right at once it got hot
that it wouldn't actually planet
oriented yeah I'm not I hope with the
people won't think I'm too weird but
like if somebody made that and we're
like yeah I made this in motor oil I
would try it
he was really curiosity he was doing
that and like in the 30s and the
hallways pretty much anything he was
doing that in the 30s and the 40s yeah
yeah like I said people wash their
Senators
it was like dry cleaning and they wash
their clothes in too
Selene and seriously I think that
RiffTrax did this on one of their shorts
I think that's probably where I saw it
because that's where I see all these
bold industrial shorts but it was like
this housewife that is blowing herself
up because you know he would also tell
me about the the the marvels of castor
oil that castor oil from the oil from
castor beans was better than any motor
oil and anything that you could have
today because I thought you were gonna
say it was good as like a [ __ ] like
it would make you [ __ ] or something no I
don't know about that castor oil was
that was a big thing back in the day of
castor oil
I remember reading a lot of the
cash-poor you could put castor oil in a
motor and basically never change the oil
yeah yeah I kind of feel like castor
always maybe like I think people were
eating it I don't know it was like as a
they put it in their hair they did
everybody gasps lean in there I don't
know if it was like as to cure
constipation I could be wrong about that
but I do I do feel like that was
something a lot of people did or it was
something they gave kids holy crap man
what this [ __ ] they used to give to kids
that's it that's like amazing although I
can't really judge cuz I used to drink
curry emulsion and straight out of the
bottle if you guys don't know what that
is it's like a chair it's like a cherry
tasting like cold medicine and it was
delicious
one time I burned my fingers it probably
had morphine like four or five and my
granddad grabbed my hand and put it in
butter which [ __ ] yeah because your
skin can't breathe you can't release any
other that yeah you really you have to
like my mom they don't put butter on his
hand wash that off and it felt better
old people didn't know anything I know
they're all dead well the funny thing
about old people is they think they know
everything they don't know anything they
don't know what they were talking about
yeah
in general they don't generally ignore
that in general they don't and general
baby-boomers don't know anything right
now
well like you got billionaire baby
boomers trying to invest sink millions
and millions of dollars into the
Internet as if it's something that they
can dominate like cable television those
old men are gonna lose their asses when
they are when they
try to take control of the internet the
Internet is it's like trying to grab
water well they don't know well you know
it's cute actually I think it's kind of
Airy cute they're gonna try and honestly
I'm not going to control the Internet
I'm not even young I'm an old person I'm
four I'll be 46
kids kids baby boomers they don't what
the [ __ ] they're talking about now wait
till Gen X gets in charge which is us
right but you know we don't believe in
it stupid [ __ ] yeah like I said old
people and I'm an old person and I'll no
[ __ ] I'm willing to admit that I'm not
I'm not like I don't get my feelings
heard about it I don't know anything
that's cool but yeah so obviously since
she had this address book that got sent
there and it had mark Hanson's name on
it so of course they crawled up his ass
but you know honestly it seems like he
didn't really you know there was this
whole thing she had this friend called
an top that was like oh yeah you know
Mark Hanson was kind of into her and he
made like sexual advances and she turned
him down a blah blah blah and so like
that kind of gave him a motive but you
know they gave him polygraph tests and
stuff and it probably wasn't him it's
like I like you said why would he send
an address book with his name on it
would never hate he I mean unless he was
a complete idiot which I don't think it
was obviously because he hasn't been
caught yeah whoever did this was
intelligent yeah so they had like over
700 investigators working on this ship
right back in the 40s and yet they still
have not solved it and like I said there
is so much like rumor so much
speculation like revolving around it was
somebody she dated somebody she knew
what is somebody like it's very rare and
like you said there aren't a lot of
related murders other than the Cleveland
torso murders which were obviously a
series of somebody that was that was
doing that to me although he largely
targeted men yeah he did kill some women
but it was its
like it was mostly men and mostly gay
men from kind of the poor neighborhoods
of Cleveland and whatnot so this seems a
little out of his bailiwick
I'm just saying so I don't think that
those two things I'm gonna say if
somebody she knew somebody she had some
kind of dealings with she did did
business with him or she dated in late
20s to 30s somebody who owned a home
somebody they had a place that was
private enough obviously because this
took a while right to do somebody who
for some reason or another could not
continue this kind of activity so maybe
a married man who decided that I didn't
really get what I needed to know this
isn't worth if I'm gonna stop or
somebody who was on the verge of maybe
getting married he did this and then he
meant meets a girl and marries some
stops because he doesn't want to
jeopardize that relationship something
along that lines I just say that you
like I said me writing true crime stuff
and you're talking this way yeah this is
why I'm terrified of men because that is
this all it takes for one nice girl to
put up with your [ __ ] and then you will
stop being a serial killer if I hadn't
met you know these guys like I'm not
talking about you I'm talking with the
Royal you I'm talking about in general
you I'm just like if this nice girl like
this hypothetical nice girl had not met
you then you would have just gone and
good just cut random women and have it
know these dudes is that what dudes are
like no we have to understand this is a
man who is a product of the 30s okay
this is very frightening for if you look
at if you work out the dates so guys
like this are not being created anymore
because the 30s are now gone all right
thankful for that whatever it was that
whatever fetish that had hold of him you
know at this time probably is not a fish
that exists today
you know said I'm talking about or or is
it better
that is easily easily fulfilled in other
files in weather so in other words maybe
something as simple as the advent of
online porn is preventing this kind of
thing
I mean it's problematic as I find some
types of porn I do think in general is
an hour it is a good thing
I'd like a pressure valve out right
because you can find pretty much
anything yeah online and you can just
watch it and not and I said 99% of dudes
that have these weird fetishes and stuff
will just be happy with that they can
see somebody else indulging it is like
the Guzzi these kind of finishes are
kind of harmless and they're just
playing right but there's always this
one weird always I have that there's
that we're doing some crazy [ __ ] had he
not had some kind of outlet yeah and you
see inhibition and restriction keeping
people [ __ ] tight and tightened up in
a little box can cause these weird
explosions of oh yeah things like the
Black Dahlia slaying and serial killers
in a way or a natural disaster you know
down about yeah natural this I guess
we're saying because of problems inside
of society right you know be a child
root and these are born with well and
they're generally people with some type
of weird or psychopathy or something
they don't know people never really go
down this path right and that's what I
mean it's like you're always going to
have because there's always going to be
a certain small very small percentage
thankfully the populations that are
going to do this type of thing and I and
I think in most cases it can be
prevented in a very small maybe a
fraction of a percent you probably can't
prevent it because that's just the way
they're wired and there's nothing you
can do about it
but I think that's a pretty vanishingly
rare percentage I think a lot of this
[ __ ] comes from guys a lot of this stuff
is coming from guys that didn't resolve
things in childhood because really when
you look at
probably very primitive type fantasies
things that are supposed to be resolved
in three and four-year-old children
talking about yes about just the basic
foundations I mean like some of them
have a hard time differentiating
differentiating between sexual desire
and desire for food so they eat the
people that they're attracted to you
know I'm talking about which is
something that kids are supposed to real
supposed to figure out the difference
every logical sexual attraction and the
traction to food to figure that out the
age to you know I mean it should be
something that simple
yeah and I'm not saying look I'm a girl
and I'm not saying that sometimes when I
look I've I've worked retail I've gone
out in public there have been many many
times where if I could have killed
someone and gotten away with it yeah I
would shame on you
but no I'm just saying just because
people sort of make you so mad that's
right
people are being just such a douche hat
I'm just like can you please just die oh
my god I have dreams I have dreams right
get mad and I stop a [ __ ] hey
greasy spot I look down there's nothing
left everybody has that everybody has
that yeah but most people know it's not
worth it really and it brings on too
much trouble sometimes you know I get a
few drinks in me in a bar I might you
might throw a fist but people get a
brochure you know what I mean yeah but
yeah so I've done that too but yeah so
it's the same kind of thing but yeah so
alright let's let's get back to the
Black Dahlia case okay so so like I said
they got a package with all this stuff
of her stuff so evidently I mean this is
probably for someone that knew her or
obviously probably from her killer now
on January 26 they got another letter
that was kind of all pasted letters and
[ __ ] and it said here it is turning in
Wednesday January 29th 10:00 a.m.
had my fun at police and it was signed
Black Dahlia Avenger so here's the guy
he's like Oh
okay I'm gonna turn myself in and all
this other [ __ ] so he tells the police
he's gonna turn himself in does he of
course not even though the police were
waiting
yeah the Black Dahlia Avenger so he
didn't turn himself in but you know the
police had to obviously you know act
like that was legit because it probably
was but then he decided not to so they
waited he didn't show up and then he
gets another they get another letter the
paper got another letter that said I've
changed my mind you would not give me a
square deal and then at the end of it it
says Dahlia killing was justified what
it was justified right so in this
person's sick little mind because she's
a [ __ ] I guess I don't like I said this
is why dudes fright they have very very
weird no very very weird guy dudes
[ __ ] lines justify yeah so so all
this stuff so so the case goes nowhere
so let's kind of talk about you know
since since the case happened and since
you know in all the decades since and I
was thinking I was like oh my god it's
been like 70 [ __ ] years and [ __ ]
happens dead well yeah but they don't
want to know who did it I mean you know
now they had a ton of false confessions
which they always do in a case of this
magnitude where it's you know all up in
the media and stuff so there was a bunch
of that kind of [ __ ] but let's kind of
talk about there were some suspects at
the time that were interviewed and
released and then there were some
suspects that kind of came along later
that were some of the ones that were you
know kind of looked at at the time but
dismissed but whatever so let's kind of
talk about now one of the ones that has
come about lately was a guy named Walter
Bailey and this I don't think they
interviewed him at the time but he was
one that he was a name that kind of came
up later on now he was a surgeon like I
said even at the time that the black
dahlia was killed they actually pulled a
huge list of everyone that was at the
UCLA or the medical schools or whatever
in the area because they said this is
some
with some medical knowledge that would
have to know how to bisect the body
without encountering bone and whatnot
you have to get them at the right you
know vertebra otherwise you know cutting
the body and half is very hard a hunter
could do it somebody who's field rested
but they're just saying they needed
somewhere to start so really sitting
there and they drained all the blood
also they're always thinking up it was a
doctor no could have been a deer hunter
or somebody you know I mean whose dad
was a deer hunter and they feel just a
few deer yeah they're always they're
always looking he's I mean yeah that's a
good place to start but yeah although
how many meters are there in law saying
in California there could there could
have been a lot back then yeah remember
it was it was more that's true it's more
borough or suburban area rural areas or
a lot of places to hide yeah hold on one
second
where you going oh yeah okay so one of
the main suspects that has been
discussed lately is a guy named Walter
Bailey now he was a surgeon in Los
Angeles now the main reason that he came
to authorities attention later on was
because he had left his wife in 1946 and
his daughter was allegedly a friend of
Elizabeth's sister now the wife the
ex-wife said that Walter Bailey had a
mistress and that Walter Bailey when he
died had left all his money to his
mistress because that she knew some kind
of secret about him implying that she
was blackmailing him and so the ex-wife
claims that the secret that the mistress
knew was that he was the one that had
killed the Black Dahlia now it should be
noted that even though he was a surgeon
he was about 67 years old at the time
the Black Dahlia was murdered which
seems a little old for somebody for this
type of crime
yeah now some people have pointed out
that it's like oh well that was the
reason that Elizabeth Short was cut in
half was because it made her easier to
transport
but he's the wrong profile that seemed
yeah it's not so little sketchy like
I've seen a couple documentaries about
this where they interviewed the ex-wife
and it's like yeah they you know it
mostly he did kind of live near where
the body was found yet okay so there is
that I'm gonna tell you there's a big
problem with that
most serial killers okay
burn out in their 40s it's because the
hormones that this type of murder is
usually hormonal II driven it's it's
with the sex drive they have a [ __ ]
high sex drive and it's [ __ ] linked up
with violence and [ __ ] these weird
fantasies a man at sixty seven just
doesn't have the drive to put himself in
this kind of danger to do something so
stupid as to [ __ ] cut some girl and
happy well now the whole thing about is
just the whole thing about this is that
they're like oh well Bailey had a neuro
neuro generative disorder which caused
some brain degeneration that caused some
violent behavior which is possible it
does happen but I'm not real sure it's
unlikely I feel like it's kind of
unlikely but he's kind of one of the
main ones that's to discuss as a young
man's crime lately yeah this seems like
a very and like I said this is somebody
that took a lot of time yeah I mean I it
doesn't seem like he took a lot of time
killing her but he's brought her took a
lot of time posing the body and making
it look the way he wanted it to look
yeah
there was another suspect named Norman
Chandler and this kind of whole thing
hinges on him having impregnated her and
stuff like that in any I have to say
that any scenario that has her being
impregnated by somebody giving them a
motive for killing her or an abortionist
or anything like that is kind of
[ __ ] because the autopsy says that
she was not pregnant and had never been
pregnant so I kind of tend to believe
that overall these kind of wild
accusations of oh well she was pregnant
with his baby and he's a
want one so that's two unlikely give him
motive so you know so anything like that
I'm kind of gonna you know look askance
at because according to the autopsy
report she had never been pregnant and
she was not pregnant when she died so it
was nothing to do with abortionists or
anything like that now another one was
Lesley Dylan who was 27 years old at the
time he was a bellhop and a former
morticians assistant now he became a
suspect when he started writing to the
LAPD psychiatrist who was named a doctor
River or dr. D River in 1948 now he was
living in Florida at the time but he had
formerly lived in LA and he said that he
had read a story about the murder in a
kind of in a magazine like they had
those true crime typos true detective
magazines back then and he was writing
to the psychiatrist about his theories
about the case which seemed a little
weird you know so they kind of started
looking into it and he said he was very
interested in sadism and like sexual
violence and things like that now he
said that he thought this friend of his
friend and I'm making bunny rabbit ears
appear listening to it on the audio
version named Jeff Connors was maybe the
killer because he knew about that kind
of stuff now for a long time the
psychiatrist was thinking oh you have a
friend you know how that goes I have a
friend that did this and that no it's
really you but they did actually find
out this Jeff Conners person was an
actual real person you know when they
investigated so they did actually find
this actual person so they actually did
meet up with this guy and all this other
kind of [ __ ] happen so this seems a
little more likely I'm not super sure
about that this is almost say okay first
of all this was a young man's crime yeah
this guy was 27 and he was the kind of
guy remember cannibal cop yeah he was a
four yeah okay he was a guy like that
where
you have a normal life and you sit
around and you have this weird fetish
that you keep fantasizing and
fantasizing about he was a guy kind of
like one of these vores yeah or he was a
guy kind of like one of these dudes that
constantly fantasizes about amputation
he's like a guy who cut off his own
finger or just get you know he was a
dude that just had this weird fetish you
know I mean yeah about cutting somebody
in half and putting faces and taking
pictures of it something having to do
with amputation or bisection it was some
kind of a fetish like that because like
I said this is a very yeah and he did it
and for some reason stopped either he
realized it wasn't satisfying or that
something else came along in his life
and he realized that well I don't want
to lose this because I'm into this and
that wasn't all that good and just it
was something like that yeah the photos
of it kept him satisfied for him long
enough to make a transition out of that
fetish yeah I want to see this dude kind
of like cannibal cop for dude who didn't
kill anybody but he was just totally
fascinated about cooking girls you know
I mean talk about cooking girls dude it
was
that's a weird totally fantasizing about
cutting some girl in half about being in
half I think that's what it was that's
kind of in him I'm not [ __ ] on
people that have fetishes because you
know everybody has them and like some of
them are weird and as long as you don't
like try to indulge them with people
that are unwilling he had some kind of
fetish about I am NOT I'm on board yeah
it's some kind of a fetish about being
in half and the person being cut in half
liked it and was happy with it that's
why he put the smile on her face the
other oh that's something I never
thought of that but that's yeah that's
why starving he pries where she was
happy but oh yeah yeah cut in half
cutting little animals along said
cutting little animals and half and
little lizards and little things in half
and they enjoyed it and he enjoyed it
and somehow he had the satisfies of the
cutting some person in half and they
liked it it was something like that cuz
I'm gonna say like I for some time as a
kid I thought it's not a fetish cuz I'm
not I don't like it I'm just I'm alarmed
by it yeah I've always had a thing about
beheading like I don't like I don't get
off on it I just find it very upsetting
and it's something that I think about a
lot because it's something that bothers
me so whenever I see it in a movie like
when I saw the omen and like [ __ ]
David Warner getting his head cut off
with the pane of glass that like really
upset me when I was a kid I was like a
whole [ __ ] oh [ __ ] cuz I was like that
really like freaked me out as heaven you
know a background is being a soldier
infantry in for me beheading was always
kind of like equated to primal and
primitive combat soldiers got real close
to one another and they fought with
blades you know talking about yeah and
you grab somebody you don't like you
don't like what they said you don't like
what they did and you overcome them
physically and you take a blade and you
cut their head off and then you have the
head by the hair see you gotcha I gotcha
[ __ ] look there you are you know I mean
and it's it's that kind of a that really
vibe that's what beheading is it's and
that's why primitive warriors it's got
the face on it got the face and now I
yeah I definitely audio that's what
bothers me about it it bothers me
because it's total it's total
emasculation you're cutting the person's
body yeah it's not even emasculate yes d
hue minutes exactly you know now you
have the head and the head is in your
hand and there he is
yeah and then you know the Japanese did
that to the Fallen enemies of the dead
they took the head and then they would
take the head before their Lord to be
paid for that kill because they were
mercenary armies that's how you prove
that you
she killed a person that killed an enemy
soldier so head hunting and taking heads
yeah it's very primal very pretty
warrior behavior because you can carry a
head easily you can't carry a body but
you can carry a head as he heads in a
duffel bag that wasn't that was a movie
right good movie you can easily identify
the head as look here here is right they
bought they brought somebody's head to
President Bush so they planned it too
what was what was it Bush President Bush
wanted what's the guy who did the 9/11
thing
Osama bin Laden his head did you hear
about that yeah when they went up there
to those mountains where they thought
they were gonna catch and they they had
a the Special Forces had a cooler with
dry ice in it to actually bring Osama
bin Laden's head back to George Bush and
that's not a lot that did happen but
they couldn't get him but that's the
thing it's like that's why everytime and
honestly the first time I read the story
about I think it was Mary Queen of Scots
and when they were beheading her and the
executioner missed the first time and
like kind of just chunked her in the
back of the head and she was still
conscious yeah and then he had to do it
a bunch of times oh I still remember
that that upset me so much we'll be
heading in that thing I read about that
type of beheading that's [ __ ] up
evidently if you were a real [ __ ]
they'd be they would miss on purpose no
they would behead you with an axe
because that's what they did to her yeah
because the accident oh yeah no the
double axe just kind of mashed your head
off
yeah if you were if they were does their
horrible if they're gonna have mercy
they used a sword because I can only
think of a few people that I would do
that's here most of the time the [ __ ]
can get mad okay oh man I could imagine
doing that I could think of a few I
haven't been in a situation where I'm
gonna be like dude I gotta cut your head
off man sorry but slowly yeah you know
I'm just gonna
I haven't been in that situation yeah
but I can I can imagine it I know I can
totally and hate is a powerful thing oh
I know yeah I know now what I don't
understand about these serial killers
though is that they have no reason to
hate these people yeah like look there
are plenty of legitimate reasons to hate
people I'm not saying I'm not saying go
kill people or behead people yeah you
get caught you're gonna do it don't do
that it's not worth the effort honestly
I'm too lazy to do [ __ ] like that anyway
I'm just saying I can understand that
like so even murders are horrible but
murders that are committed like in the
heat of an argument or something like
that yeah like so it's not justifiable
right but it's understandable right like
we've all been moving into my house you
threatened her if I had children you
think it's gonna get bad it's just gonna
get yeah that's what I mean it's like
even if I was out if I was at [ __ ]
7-eleven getting coffee and he
threatened me you I yeah I would be very
glad about it if I can Shawn would cute
girl because you're attracted to her
you're gonna cut her head off I don't
really understand that's what I mean
that is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right there
it's it's almost taking like an
understandable human emotion yeah and
just like crosswire knit with this like
watch
yeah xDrive and [ __ ] vile you're
relating it to something that it doesn't
have any relation to that's what kind of
kills me of this whole black dahlia
thing it's like look it's like I don't
know if she did like I'm not saying I'm
not blaming the victim or anything like
that but it's like did she piss you off
or did she like turn you down for a date
or something like that which in no way I
would say justifies anything like that
but it's like why would give you
incentive to do something that extreme I
would say by the condition of the body
that that didn't happen the condition of
the body was is that she was cut in half
for sexual fetishists reasons that it
seems very phonetic to the guy who did
this fantasized that she enjoyed it
that's how and I never thought of that
but the way that her face was yet into
the smile like that that could suggest
that sure that's what I think I actually
never
that but yeah that does seem like she
was complicit in it yeah no she liked it
she liked it right which that is like
extra [ __ ] up
and that's why okay so probably in
recent years the most famous suspect for
this has been dr. George Hill Hodel and
this came about because his son Steve
Hodel who used to be a police detective
he wrote a book called the Black Dahlia
Avenger in which he accused his father
who died in 1999 of having killed the
Black Dahlia
yeah which now okay I saw some
compelling he did I saw I saw a
documentary about this I've read parts
of the book he does have some compelling
and it should be noted dr. hurdle was a
suspect at the time yeah he was such a
suspect that they bugged his house so
they do have some recordings of him
saying some pretty incriminating [ __ ]
like he did say something like supposing
I did kill the Black Dahlia there's no
he said something like there's no
proving it now they can't talk to my
secretary because she's dead his
secretary root Spalding had died a short
time earlier from a quote-unquote
overdose now he was supposedly there
when this overdose happened and she had
supposedly been going to go to either
the press or whatever authorities
because of some cuz he was a doctor he
was he actually ran a a sexually
transmitted disease clinic he wasn't a
surgeon surgeon but he did run a clinic
and so she was evidently planning to go
to the authorities about some kind of
sketchy financial [ __ ] that he was into
or he was like you know doing some kind
of [ __ ] like that so she was apparently
going to go so there was a lot of
speculation that he had murdered her but
they could never prove it so he was
under surveillance so it's not like and
also his daughter Tamar who was 14
used him of molesting her at the time
that doesn't equate though right but I'm
just saying that it's not like he was
snowy white and people are just like
accusing this guy of nothing he was
actually under the radar at the time oh
yeah if you see in the house is still
standing it's like this huge house I
think it's called Franklin Drive
nowadays or whatever but it's this huge
it looks like a Mayan temple his house
and you can still go to the house they
did it on [ __ ] ghost hunters and [ __ ]
like that they went there as far as I
saw some pictures of Zak and all them in
front of this [ __ ] house but the
house it has like secret passages and
[ __ ] like that and apparently he was
kind of like a high up he was a doctor
so he had a lot of money and he knew
some famous people so was he at the time
I'm not sure you see 30s or 40s and he
had some kind of famous friends and they
had allegedly had some parties at this
Mayan temple looking house that he had
which like I said is still standing it's
still there there's pictures of it on
Google and so evidently there's been
some accusations that he had offered up
daughters and other teenage girls to
various people in Los Angeles that he
knew other kind of business owners right
things of that nature so there have been
allegations like that so like I said I'm
not saying that the dude he's dead now
so he can't defend himself the problem
that I'm kind of finding with this yeah
like I said some of the stuff that Steve
Hodel says in his book is actually kind
of compelling he kind of thinks that oh
his handwriting
his dad's handwriting looked like
handwriting that had been attributed to
the Black Dahlia killer or whatever but
the reason that he first started
suspecting his dad was because oh I was
looking through my dad's things after he
died and I saw these two photos and they
looked just like Elizabeth Short and I
thought oh well he must have known her
but I've seen these two pictures at
least he knew about her half is
I've seen these two photographs that
were allegedly Elizabeth Short and I'm
not saying they're not her but they
don't look that much like her to me one
of them kind of could be her but it was
kind of like the angle was weird and
it's like I couldn't really know I'm now
some people have allegedly said that he
did know her yeah I'm gonna say no I'm
gonna say that's not him you know why I
think he won he's a little too old to I
think he's a little too too functional
too high-functioning I think the guy who
did this actually did have privacy but I
think it was more of a looser type
although I kind of suspect he might have
killed his secretary I'm you know yeah
they did kind of have there were a
couple other ones but I see a couple
other ones it was one named George
Knowlton but that was another one where
the thing is after this whole Black
Dahlia Avenger by Steve Hodel came out
like I said I was willing to give him
the benefit of the doubt in the first
book I'm like okay that sounds legit I'm
not saying that his dad was killed the
Black Dahlia it's possible sure he did
probably know her they probably ran in
the same circles he could have done it
but you know at this stage it kind of
seems like then everybody came out of
the wood yo my dad is the black dahlia
killed my dad's the zodiac my dad and
then Steve Hodel comes out with these
other subsequent books that said that
his dad was also the zodiac then he had
also done all these other murders and
I'm like you know you just pissed away
any goodwill that you might have had
this to go did this slipped under the
radar I kind of feel like this might
have been it sure it could have been a
serial killer but it was maybe somebody
that wasn't it was a one-time killer it
was either a one-off or they didn't
really catch him on the other ones and
it was somebody I like I said I feel
like this was a personal crime I got a
feeling this is a this was his first
homicide and his last he was it doesn't
happen
he was it's rare but it happened he was
a fetish series
kill her or he was a fetish killer he
would have been a serial killer but for
some reason he stopped serial killer do
you have to kill three but that's just a
that's just an FBI definition yeah
that's a number it's just an it only one
person is bad enough and it's hard to
it's it's hard to quantify people and
human behavior under normal
circumstances he would have been a
serial killer but for some reason he
stopped maybe he killed himself maybe he
went to prison
maybe he got married and decided to stop
maybe he had a change of heart something
like that yeah
but I have a feeling this guy wasn't as
functional or successful as a doctor I
you know I mean I think yes I think he
was you know kind of a kind of a
scuzzbag kind of a wannabe which I feel
like most serial killers I like I think
that's a myth that I think it maybe it's
because of Silence of the Lambs like
Hannibal Lecter super intelligent
psychology I don't think most of them
are like that I think most I don't think
they're idiots necessarily but I think a
lot of them are just average and I think
there was some kind of a connection with
her Oh their muscle it wasn't as deep as
they're trying to make it right I don't
think he dated her I think he just knew
about her yeah I think where he became
fixated maybe he saw her and got her
maybe in his mind it was a much more of
a connection right and she wouldn't even
know his name
right she probably didn't even know he
was it was like a star I feel like it
was a stopped-up type situation like
somebody that had developed this whole
entire relationship with her without
really knowing about it I kind of feel
like that because all the people that
knew her that were suspects because
obviously Redman Leigh was a suspect cuz
he was the last guy to see her alive
even though he did help the police he
identified the shoes in the bag it's
like yeah that's hers and he was like
not even around
it's they you know they gave him a
polygraph test he was you know kind of
exonerated but also mark Hanson whose
name was on the book he was kind of a
little bit of sleazebag maybe he was
kind of into her and stuff like that but
I kind of feel like he didn't really
have much motive otherwise I just feel
like this was
but he that like you said was like
someone from afar maybe had seen this
was some kind of all nerdy in cell what
you would call today at himself
yeah involuntary celibate and you know
very cringy you wouldn't want to be
around him yeah probably like some big
overweight guy who was kind of in area
you know [ __ ] late term virgin you
know it's all about maybe you know
thirty five you know virgin type
something like that I kind of feel like
it's more I feel like the the mains they
can do this I'm gonna cut you in half
you're gonna love it yeah I'm gonna cut
my fingertips off and I'm gonna like it
so there's got like that I kind of feel
like if if they're gonna ever find out
who did this I feel like it was somebody
not one of the main suspects but I think
it was someone on the periphery like I
it was somebody that knew her or knew
somebody that knew her but was not maybe
wasn't like friends of hers like say he
lived on her block probably or like
somebody like this this nest next
suspect who is Patrick O'Reilly yeah who
was a she was a doctor too but he was
actually only an acquaintance of hers
and he knew her through mark Hanson so
it was like a friend of a friend and
also he had been in prison for other
things like other sexually violent type
of crime so I feel like it's probably
somebody like that that wasn't like
super associated with her but knew
somebody that knew her and just kind of
like saw her I was like yeah I'm gonna
get that it seemed like something like
that sort of case because this like a
medical background thing though if you
ask me that's not necessarily so red it
doesn't have to because you have medical
manuals all throughout you know I mean
the lawyers come by whatever you want
and these guys that are into you know
amputations and weird amputation
fetishes they buy that kind of crap and
they learn about that kind of crap
before they do it true yeah I mean so so
it doesn't necessarily like I said like
the whole thing about Jack the Ripper
it's like there's kind of a things like
had to be a doctor and how did he like
did he stand out in Whitechapel because
it was working class and blah blah but
it's like you don't you know it's it's
easier nowadays I guess but back then in
Victorian London even then you didn't
have to be a doctor necessarily like you
said you could have been a butcher yeah
something just interested or a hunter or
somebody that knew how to cut up animals
because a human is just I mean they're
no different than a deer or any other
animal so yeah and the difference in
shape is actually slight yeah so if you
knew how to dress it field Reza deer as
you said then doing it to a human would
not be that difficult so it you don't
have to be a surgeon necessarily you
know I do see how they're kind of like
oh well you have to know like exactly
where to bisect the body and blah blah
blah but it's like it's the same ah it's
a good but yeah it's a good place to
start yeah but I don't think that that's
that can't be the be-all end-all of your
investigation so you know there were
some other there were some other suspect
Jack Anderson Wilson who was actually
kind of a serial killer he got kind of
caught for some other [ __ ] later how we
doing on time there were a couple of
other female suspects because like I
said there were a bunch of rumors about
of the black dahlia was gay and also
that kind of stuff but that's never been
substantiated that seemed like some
other like some say she's sensational
istic [ __ ] there were a couple of
celebrity suspects Woody Guthrie the
folk singer for whatever reason Orson
Welles I don't know why Bugsy Seigel no
the you know the very famous gangster
some people thought he had something to
do with it I don't know why but yeah so
I don't know about that and you know so
there have been a lot of other [ __ ] like
that like other they don't know who did
that well I mean there's some little
nerdy Insel who lived on her block or
knew about her and he had this weird
fetish about cutting things in half and
then enjoying it that's what I say this
is yeah I feel like that's probably it's
not that's probably this yeah and I
don't know like I said there were no
other there were a couple of other sort
of similar like I said some people have
tried to connect this to the murder of
George at Barrow Dorf
and I think the problem there is that
they try to relate it because they're
like oh well they both worked at the
same place except they didn't
yeah georgette bardarf worked at this
one club that was like a G you know all
the GIS hung out there and there was
some weird perception that the black
dahlia worked there as well but she
didn't the black dahlia didn't move
there until after that place was already
closed now georgette Meredith was
actually found in her apartment she had
been raped and she was found facedown in
her bathtub somebody had killed her like
that so they think it was someone that
followed her home from the club but the
whole thing about relating those crimes
was that oh well those two girls knew
each other but I don't think they did
because I don't think Elizabeth Short
had actually moved to LA until a couple
of years after that place had closed so
they didn't both work at the same place
so you know whatever that like I said I
wrote about georgette borrowed or from
my first book but there's also some [ __ ]
about you know why she was called the
Black Dahlia and [ __ ] like that but you
know that was probably from one there
was a film noir out called the Blue
Dahlia which you know sick camp thing
but also she had super black hair some
people said oh she wore a little flowers
like dollies and her hair and you know
the press at the time oh she always wore
black clothes which I don't think she
did but whatever part of the legend it
is yes so I I feel like there's so much
legend like surrounding this case and
this poor woman it seems like this poor
woman she gets murdered and cut in half
and then everybody is like you [ __ ] god
I hope I never have this to me that's
good as I mean like I'll be dead I won't
care but it's like you know she doesn't
care she's dead but it for her family
and stuff that must have really sucked
she was a normal chick perfect that's
all it is and it's like and it sucks
because he did some fucked-up she was
just a normal chicken now 70 years later
yeah every time you say her name it's
like Rizzo the chick that got many
movies on her you're making movies about
it that's like that's [ __ ] up yeah I
just hope that ever happen oh yeah
we've got off we've been going on for
like almost two hours
I know worse well we've been drinking
that's alright so I know we didn't
really come to any resolution and I'm
sorry about that and look he's taken off
he's not even he's not even helping me
and the show
he just took get your dumb ass back
Black Dahlia is unsolved well yeah we'll
never be solved everything I write about
is right you just have to like learn to
be like here's all the videos and all
this [ __ ] and that's not what it was if
they had a good suspect he'd have been
convicted the the suspects that weren't
convicted weren't good cess well and
most of the suspects that they had at
the time are dead now yeah so even if
they definitively proved hey it was that
guy you can't do anything to him because
he's dead because the suspects that were
names do not fit the profile they
probably didn't do it no like I'm not
saying that might not have been some of
them like I said I do kind of feel like
that I'm like it would have been an
indictment if it was likely right but he
probably did some other [ __ ] yeah and
someone would probably did other [ __ ]
close it down but I know about that's
close yeah all right so he's so bossy
you got the time he said bought the time
it doesn't matter all right so all right
so we're gonna wrap this show up hope
you guys have enjoyed this whole video
episode unless you're any way so
remember if you like the show to like
share subscribe and all your social
media remember to look if you watch the
video version of the show we're not only
on YouTube anymore we're also on [ __ ]
shoot we're also on Pheo
we're also on dailymotion so look us up
on there too yeah it subscribe sure
subscribe I don't you even if you don't
watch that [ __ ] on right just grab on
this so it looks good you know what I
mean yes that'll help us any algorithms
yeah yeah so I also hope you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page you have $1,000 a
month patreon yeah I have to you don't
have to ok you just like it
go to our patreon page at patreon.com
slash lotion o'clock podcast and you can
give them up like donation or you can go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress calm and give a one-time
donation through paypal there's a little
link in the sidebar you will see it
where it says gift through PayPal and
you can do that to also go to ours as
well search in zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock we have a bunch of t-shirts
which you can wear good cuz man said
you're good they are very nice I
designed them myself
yeah so they're cool you can rip with
Atlanta with you with you interpret
right also I'm gonna put a link in the
description to my jello game store where
you can purchase the game that I should
cross shirts yeah I have a crush yeah I
got one [ __ ] Snake Plissken yeah I do
and check this out got my nice a starry
sky my friend Michael who sings for a
story night look at pretty [ __ ]
wood is pretty hair got that pretty
white it's hard to see him on there but
yeah I mean yes he looks kind of like a
very very young thin Robert Smith yeah
he has like the big 80s guy yeah which
we love I love big 80s guy fair but yeah
so yeah check is stirring it out too and
also check out our latest movie review
which was a boy and his dog from 1975
apocalyptic yeah
fallout type movie well yeah follow it
was kind of based on it yeah and I think
that will do it for episode 104 which
has gone on for far longer than any
other our great ending talks of what me
okay okay listen to this [ __ ] I have to
put up with this every day okay so this
is the end of episode 104 be sure to
tune in every Tuesday for regular
episodes and every Friday for our movie
reviews and we will see you next time
bye
[Music]
they call me birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in Hollywood working hard to get what I
should
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]